before we get into this week's recap I
want to give you an official trigger
warning based off the content of this
episode you know yourself if you're not
in the right headspace no form of
entertainment is worth potentially
making that worse take care of yourself
when I met Mary I was in a point in my
life where I was like done with
everything I didn't feel like I was good
enough for anyone not even myself and I
try to take my own wife
wow Brandon reveals that Mary gave him a
reason to live after contemplating
taking his own life
this is 90 day replay travel size where
I pack in all you need to know while
keeping it light hey 90 day fans fam
it's melissia I read a few of your
comments from last week's episode and
you made some good points which we'll
get into what you want me to do
that's it
starting from the top this episode picks
up after Mary starts having a panic
attack when Brandon confronts her about
her extreme jealousy after she
constantly told him to stop looking at
girls at church and that he could only
look at the priest and her that girl is
one giant red flag I didn't say it
Stewie did but she doesn't have to be a
red flag she just has to be willing to
do the work
someone in the comments said Mary
telling him all this in church is the
funniest part what happened to Love Thy
Neighbor what happened to do unto others
as you would have them do unto you what
if the tables were turned and Brandon
told her she can't look at men at church
she wouldn't even be able to look at the
priest do you have an inhaler she has
asthma
hey stop
it's looking like he's experienced this
before which makes me think of Beverly's
comment she says Mary's behavior is
quote a thing of control she is using
panic attacks as a form of control I'm
not gonna lie the same thought popped up
in my mind is having a panic attack a
way for her not to confront the real
issue I came to the conclusion that in
my opinion we don't have enough
information to say that is the case
right now but one thing is clear either
way whether she is really having a panic
attack or just being manipulative she
should consider talking to somebody
a therapist and if she doesn't want to
do that because some people aren't into
it find other ways to prioritize her
healing because if she doesn't
this is looking like
it can get real dangerous
okay
open your mouth girl try to breathe
there you go
in here
as Mary calms down Brandon Walks off to
talk to the camera now for all of us who
are wondering why Brandon is still with
Mary although things are clearly toxic
who reveals the answer and unfortunately
it makes sense when I met Mary I was in
a point in my life where I was like done
with everything
[Music]
I had a mom who was using
I didn't feel like I was good enough for
anyone not even myself and I try to take
my own wife
[Music]
foreign
they both have such deep pain
it's palpable
it's like two broken people came
together and now they're relying on one
another to hold into place their broken
pieces that's going to get so tiring
it's tiring now
Mary reached out for the first time
let's just say it was like the literal
definition of a life Ginger
I clung on so hard
I love this woman
I do
which is why it hurts so much when I
feel like I don't have this Trust
because it brings me back to the state
of mind like I'm not good enough
and I'm trying
really hard it's just
hold on
that's why it's so hard
this is the epitome of hurt people hurt
people and this is why it's not smart to
take how other people treat you
personally because most of the time how
they treat you is more about them than
it is about you all of us can see
Brandon is good enough Mary knows
Brandon is good enough her actions are
not because he's not good enough it's
because she's insecure but because
Brandon seems to already have a
deep-seated belief that he's not enough
he's triggered
I'm telling you from my experience
relationships are like mirrors they can
show you what you think and believe
about yourself are you okay
I'm sorry
I'm not sure why he's saying sorry
I love you
okay
I trust you and I really love you
you know that right
is there anything you want to say right
now
[Music]
I want her to say that she does
genuinely trust me
so that we can be together married
forever
right now that is the most important
thing to me
I really need that
Mary doesn't tell him that but she goes
on to also apologize
sorry
okay sorry now Brandon don't condone the
behavior fast forward to the next day
Brandon and Mary both seem to be in a
better mood Brandon has on his short
sleeved t-shirt and Mary takes him to
her High School where she has some good
memories that's when she says something
that brings tears to Brandon's eyes this
time
happy tears I hope that you understand
it's hard for me to trust you
like now today
just give me time because
I have this feeling of no matter how I
try everyone will leave me no matter
what I do
I completely understand Papi
I've had people leave me too
and I know you can't like automatically
just flip a switch and just be like okay
yes I trust him right away yeah but I
will try harder to trust you just know
that I loved you you're so perfect and
the man that I want and I really want my
future with you
he really needed to know it's not him
you mean all that to me
I love you so much
just as much puppy
thank you don't cry that means a lot to
me thank you for reassuring me don't cry
I'm trying not to although this moment
appears to be sweet Brandon puts too
much of his power in Mary's hand and
Mary puts too much of her power in
Brandon's hand
period and next week they faced a new
set of issues I don't think we're going
to have enough to pay for the bills next
month is there any chance that we could
ask for some help I just don't want to
ask help we're in a hole right now
Mary and Brandon might be taking on a
relationship and responsibilities that
they are not mature enough to handle yet
I can't wait to see these two at the
tell-off I need a real-time update
all right 90 day fans fam make sure you
stick with ET because we are covering it
all I will see you next time